last weekend we turned our clocks back
an hour and now it is time to also
change your watering clock we check in
with Southern Nevada Water Authority the
sponsors of this segment for more
well as we head into the winter season
there's some things to keep in mind when
it comes to Watering your plants and
your yard and who better to turn to than
our friend Toby bickmore from snwa Toby
let's break it all down what are some
things to keep in mind as we head into
this new season when it comes to those
mandatory watering times so starting
November 1st we're in Winter watering
schedule so it's November 1st through
the end of February which basically
means you can only water one day a week
and so that's the big thing doesn't
matter what type of landscaping you have
you can only water one day a week if you
have grass you know one day a week is
enough you know especially with the
nights cooling off and everything you
know it's okay for the plants other
types of plants in the winter time you
can probably water you know one to two
times like over a couple of weeks you
don't have to water as much we always
say the other thing in the winter time
is water a little bit later in the day
so don't water super early we do get
kind of cold in the you know in the
January time and so you don't want to
have water freezing and things like that
so
um obviously with the situation we have
going on with the water right now and
the drought we're going to go into tier
two shortages next year we're gonna have
more Cuts so it's just really important
that we follow those watering schedules
throughout the year yeah and as you
mentioned it is very important to follow
those schedules but I think a lot of us
are wondering how to even figure that
out well how do we figure out our day
what advice you have for people as
they're getting ready to set those
clocks for the new season so our website
is a great resource so if you don't know
we send a lot of mail that says this is
your watering day but if you're not sure
visit our website snwa.com and you can
look up your address and you can find
out you know what day a week to water
and so you know that's just a real good
tool to use you know for resources and
you touched on it a little bit but once
you figure out your day and what's
allowed how do you gauge how much how
little where do you go with that when it
comes to your own personal watering yeah
so for for grass usually the general
idea is you're going to water three
times for about four or five minutes
right and so that's anybody has Turf
it's kind of the same philosophy across
the board if you have Desert Landscaping
it's a little bit different because you
can have plants that are really desert
type and some that are higher water use
but generally speaking you're going to
water just once not three times and
you're gonna water anywhere from like 15
minutes to 30 to 40 minutes and again
maybe once a week but when it gets
really cold maybe once every two weeks
all right well this is really helpful
and we are all about conserving water
and money so any other tips that you
have for us at home as we head into the
new season yeah so there's a couple of
things so the the biggest thing we have
right now is if you have grass that you
don't use take that grass out we provide
a rebate for it but grass uses the most
water which means it's going to cost you
the most in your bill the other thing is
watch Water waste so you know you can
check on other people too in the
community you know see if anybody else
is wasting water but you're yourself if
you're losing water out on the street if
you have leaks you know that's water
that you're paying for so definitely
look at that and then we have some other
rebates on our website snwa.com one of
them is actually an irrigation
controller that runs all your
landscaping that's what we call Smart
and so it actually can save you some
money too
thank you to Southern Nevada Water
Authority for sponsoring this segment
call
702-258 save or visit
snwa.com for more information